raise as much money as we can to feed
that hungry animal to take this
advancing advancement in scientific
knowledge and move it forward as fast as
we can the intellectual capital is in
place the technology is in place the
diagnostic tools are there we need to
put the money and the resources in the
hands of the researchers so that they
can resolve this it is resolvable it's a
matter of dollars moving through the
knowledge forward faster well they can
call us or they go to WWDC RFQ org or
call six four six four nine seven twenty
six hundred two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars funds one researcher
that is the typical size of a research
grant many of our partners our donors
our corporations fully fund a researcher
we recognize them we associate them with
the researcher and they love that and
they get the benefit of hearing about
the progress but every gift counts
cumulatively that 40 million comes from
donors large and small so no one should
feel their dollar doesn't make a
difference because it is the collective
resources that are going to resolve this
we would welcome the support of everyone
listening to this be assured that the
dollars you invest with us are well and
wisely and efficiently invested our
medical advisory board second to none
really knows where the best research is
taking place and we're putting the money
in the hands of those researchers and
we're doing it with the smallest
overhead of any breast cancer
organization in the country
member